hallo klicks um high fanta4 meine video
frage ist was macht ihr vier jungs denn
wenn ihr so zusammen abhängt in eurer
freizeit
wollte ich mal wissen da ist
wahrscheinlich gemeint was wir da
einzelne von uns in seiner freizeit
macht das ist ganz verschieden aber was
machen wenn wir viel zusammen abhängen
dann machen wir wieder machen genau das
wir hängen tatsächlich ab
rum und chillen und doch natürlich jetzt
mode und thomas zocken die ganze zeit
schön wäre es wenn wir abhängen schon
das motto also ja stimmt ja so ein
bisschen hubschrauber rumfliegen
videospiele auf iphones oder computer
spielen
musik hören
rauchen und trinken
also auch alkoholhaltige getränke
alkoholhaltige getränke
und filmen buchmann film an zusammen ich
glaube es genauso wie du was du machst
das machen wir auch nur vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger
bescheiden hat ihr weiteres